but you don't
noah cyrus dressed up as kim kardashian
for halloween
and blessed us with an epic keeping up
with the kardashians reenactment
yeah you know the scene the one where
kim went full blown
beast mode on her sister courtney if you
had a
business you were passionate about then
you wouldn't know what it takes to run a
business but you don't so don't leave it
out like you know what i'm talking about
yeah that scene maybe if you had a
business that you were passionate about
then you wouldn't know what it takes to
run a
business but you don't so don't even
know what i'm talking about
she really has that savage kardashian
sister sass
on lock don't even have like you know
what i'm talking about
and guys it gets even better because
noah's kim costume was just
half of the full look i'm like super
blessed super happy
the 20 year old singer and her pal tana
mojo dressed up as
kim and her pal paris hilton and to
quote paris herself
that's hot loves it thank you so
so so so much noah with the gold mini
dress and
long dark hair extensions tana with a
silver mini dress and the famous dj's
signature blonde locks
you just got to put it all out there and
own it noah shared a few solo snaps of
her look on instagram
and got a lot of love in the comments
her big sis miley cyrus wrote quote
you are perfection i love you so much
baby girl
while demi lovato hit her with a fire
emoji
as for tana that wasn't her only paris
inspired halloween costume this year
it's h-i-l-c-o-n
paris the 22-year-old teamed up with
fellow youtube star ashley schwann
to channel paris and nicole richie circa
the simple life
season one tana captioned the pic quote
huh
how'd we do paris hilton nicole richie
we had to
working is hard well paris weighed in
hitting up the comments to write what
else
that's hot loves it and hashtag iconic
af
i love it tana also dressed up with jake
paul going as
tiger king stars joe exotic and a sexy
carol baskin
then there was this costume oh
hi i'm elle woods and for my admissions
essay i'm gonna be telling all of you at
harvard why i'm gonna be an amazing
lawyer
yeah she went all el woods legally
blonde even putting her
own twist on that harvard admissions
video as
president of my sorority i'm skilled at
commanding the attention of a room and
discussing very important issues
it has come to my attention that the
maintenance staff is switching our
toilet paper
from charmin to generic
all those opposed to chafing please say
aye
and swapped this line hey l do you know
what happened on days of our lives
yesterday
why yes margo i do for a
kardashian-inspired line
avi hey l do you remember what happened
on keeping up with the kardashians
yesterday
why yes amari i do we joined kendall and
kylie in a tough battle with our
sisterhood
as you know the devil works hard but
kris jenner works harder